so today I'm going to give you I didn't
really know the audience that I would be
facing so some of the star
talking you may already know and other
stuff may be too much but hopefully
you'll at least pick up something I like
to give you a little bit of my personal
view of how this deep learning neural
network technology has changed over a
period of a few decades as Andy was
mentioning so let's start with a little
bit of history and in this case both
artificial intelligence and machine
learning when I go and talk to people
they say well so what's the difference
and they're actually very similar in
some cases like one way that I like to
say artificial intelligence to people my
neighbor that may be a doctor or a
lawyer doesn't know much about
technologies things that are very easy
for people to do like you can see a
known face and you can just recognize
them right away and I supposed to
machine intelligence I give you
I ask you to multiply two numbers 15
digits each well you learn how to do
that about 15 digits you probably can
make a mistake you sweat a little bit
and yet for the computer is like no
problem so that's the machine
intelligence versus the artificial
intelligence in things that are easy for
us and not the problem that that has is
that it's easy for us how can it is that
stupid machine cannot do it right and
that's been the way for many many
decades so let's start with a little bit
of history this is like back in 1950
Alan Turing creating the string test to
propose what intelligences the and maybe
later on in 55 there was this workshop
in Dartmouth College and they figure out
these these well-known people hey we can
crack this up like pretty quickly maybe
a summer and maybe a couple of years
well they were kind of optimistic but
there was some progress made this is one
of the first artificial intelligence
programs that was built by Arthur Samuel
at IBM in the 50s and you can see that
here then there was Eliza which is in
some case the precursor of Siri and
others and it was amazing what it could
do at that time and because of that the
expectations were really inflated so if
you can do this and I know that you're
just paraphrasing what I say so how do
you feel what you asked me that but it
just really not intelligence but
if you can already do that in 1966 this
is not gonna be too long until we crack
the problem right in fact Stanley
Kubrick visited Bell Labs in the sixties
and we're starting to create science
fiction movies and he's a wall I will
talk to these guys to feel anticipate
what's coming and he already saw the
first speech synthesizers the first
speech recognizers just very rudimentary
and so well fast-forward I think in 2001
this is done yeah well actually he got
one thing wrong not not only that it's
not done in 2001 he's not even done
today but the Machine Hal was huge now
we have the computers are much smaller
much more powerful so he didn't get that
wrong in the other direction and then VA
a winner came and for many years
especially AI and machine learning like
if you say that you were doing AI they
would look at us mmm what the heck are
you doing so I was in the late 80s I saw
the winner because especially in the
neural network part the more traditional
machine learning more probabilistic and
graphical models that was you know doing
fine but I was doing my fist at CMU in
the late eighties and my officemate was
doing something on neural networks and
was fine so I graduated and he still was
there so I would come once in a while to
this is my former adviser and say hi he
was still there and then I come to from
here he was still there finally
eventually he graduated and I said you
know what I'm not gonna attach neural
networks this is not not good so I saw
the winner first hand but there was a
Renaissance in the late 90s this is one
of the examples that started to
popularize the work a machine that can
beat the world champion of chess we take
it for granted now but back then Wow I
saw one of the people that work at IBM
on this was actually a professor at CMU
and then moved to IBM so I saw some of
the early prototypes so it wasn't a
surprise but how do people my god you
can do that the machines can't really
think so the expectations
started to skyrocket you know Stanford
how these are challenged the DARPA Grand
Challenge in a car could drive by itself
for a number
of my of miles in the desert is like wow
this is really coming so so and then
deep learning the term tip learning has
been going on for a number of years but
it hadn't really caught up very much and
I like to ELISA tribute this paper
science paper that Geoff Hinton did in
2006 as one of the milestones where if
you look at in the number of citations
or the appearance of that term in the
papers started to go up so it's not like
deep learning was born at that time but
that's one point where it was an
inflection point I will tell you what is
that was in this particular paper a
little bit later and then of course
jeopardy when we can be the computer
that can beat the the champions of
jeopardy that was even more impressive
than chess because here you really need
to be a person I mean and that's what's
really so the expectations kept going up
so you came up at that here until then
when I would talk to my neighbors again
that were not into technology and they
tell me so what did you do I would say
well I work on a speech recognition
speech one so I tried to explain what
we're having the glass of wine and I
said what Oh
so when the machine talks and all that
speech synthesis speech recognition
speech synthesis and the guy stops
thinking I got it
the other day my internet wasn't working
so I call the internet company to
complain and he stopped talking to a
person I talked to this stupid machine
that he didn't understand is that what
you do and say okay you want to have
treating someone so for many years this
was just an academic pursuit because it
wasn't really practical and yes there
were a few applications out there but
they were only working when they were
very very constrained and when people
tried to make it less constrained and
they faced a regular user that was not
the guy that knew how the system work
and knew how to do the demos and know
how to work it just basic fell apart but
this is the time where it achieved
mainstream mainstream in not in the
sense that is a solved problem because
it's not in the sense that people knew
what the technology was you didn't need
to say speech recognition you didn't
know what would to explain they knew all
theory I get it
and yeah it works sometimes that some
other times it doesn't works like
so but it was a big milestone - I
mentioned the Turing test before there
was a competition that was done by a you
know entrepreneur that was trying to
come up with like the dilemma price was
called trying to come up with a
competition to see if someone could be
in a chatbot that would pass the Turing
test and in 2014 it did pass it
according to the definition because it's
full more than 30% of the judges the
idea is that you as a judge I start
tapping through a chap interface and
then you see responses back and someone
is to decide am I talking to a person or
am I talking to a computer and 30% of
the time they fooled the judges they
thought I were talking to a computer but
not a person but it was actually this
computer interesting enough this chapel
was called Eugene Guzman which was
supposed to be a fourteen-year-old
Ukrainian and that was not just random
there was a by design 14 year olds so
that you know you cannot expect that
knows everything in the world so you ask
a question doesn't quite answer it right
hey so 14 year old Ukrainian well it's
not a native speaker of English so
sometimes the grammar is not right
that's in quite understand so that made
it easier but that was still quite an
interesting milestone it more recently
Google and I did my heart alphago
that I don't think it was people were as
impressed because most people in the US
don't know what goal is so okay you win
adapter okay I'm fine I don't even know
what it is but the program is really
very difficult so it is like a big
achievement so this is kind of like a
brief history yes cars were not AI I
mean he was very disappointed by the
progress yes yeah this is an area where
the expectations are so high because
we're just thinking we're talking to a
person and we imitate some aspects of
that but it's not really doing the same
thing from a surface it may look like
you're talking to our human
this Shabbat but you know it's not and
it just fools you within constraint of
just having that chatbot actual
conversation for five minutes there's a
lot more work to do so I hope that we
have some students in in the in the room
that are going to work on this and
trying to to solve the problems because
there are many and I will hopefully show
you some of them so let's go into a
little bit of the description of what
machine learning is which is similar to
AI but not quite as machine learning is
kind of like us I tell some of my
friends fancy math that is used to solve
some of these problems it's a special
type of math AI probably is more than
just our machine learning in that sense
and there were a couple of definitions
that at least I liked back from Arthur
Samuel at IBM back in the 50s it tells
you is the study that gives the
computers ability to learn without being
explicitly programmed like I suppose to
a rule-based system where if the system
doesn't do something correctly you just
write if this happens then do that and
you write more rules and you know
hopefully you can solve the problem
instead of here no you don't need to
write code when you do that it's only
you give me some data and the system has
a program that will learn how to improve
a more mathematical description Tom
Mitchell game is you have a task T and
you want to define a performance metric
P and based on experience E or some data
you want to measure improvements by the
way every time that I see a picture
still chuckle like the machine learning
but what is examples of of machine
learning problems well one of them is
and this is one that was worked on in
the 90s when email starting to take off
spam messages came up so is this email
message spam or is it legitimate that's
a machine that's that's the task does
the job that you trying to do and the
metric is the percentage of emails that
are correctly classified it is spam and
yes in fact is spam I don't put
legitimate emails in the spam folder
which as you know it happens sometimes
or likewise you get an email that is
supposed to be legitimate and yet is
spam so it's not a hundred percent even
today and then you have a database of
emails with
Able's someone in this case is
supervised learning someone gave you the
labels and you say well this time and
this is not so this one example
recognize you handwritten words it's not
a binary class in this case and is the
percentage of words that are correctly
recognized and you have a database ah
I'm not ill in this case to playing
checkers we saw an example where that's
the task and how many times did you win
the system win and how many times you
lose and then in this case do
reinforcements in and look at your data
as you can play can see each other or
some other games it's not just only
games that have been annotated from
humans or in the case of automobile
you're driving in the in the highway
using all these sensors and how long do
you travel until a human detects that
that there was a mistake in the other
autonomous car and then you have all
these data to train so those are some of
the examples so let's look at a little
bit of math of a binary star with binary
classification so let's start with the
example where you're trying to detect if
this tumor is breast cancer or not it is
it benign or is it malignant that's the
simple question and I only give you one
feature now your input is the tumor size
and now you need to make a decision I
classify is this benign or malignant
just if I give you this size well maybe
if I let's say it's a single feature so
I just plot them there and in this case
that's the data and that would be the
decision that's kind of like the happy
case if I do that a great and if it is
on this side I say it's a big benign
tumor and if he's on the other side is a
malignant tumor this is what it's called
linearly separable and that's again the
happy case in reality life is not so
good so easy and you cannot do that like
if you draw just a line there you cannot
do that and you have on earth and that's
the case that is not linearly separable
which is most of the time what's going
on so what do you do in that case you
measure the errors and you do okay most
of the time but there are all these
errors
is there something that you can do well
one possibility
you have a cost function which this case
may be the errors it doesn't need to be
symmetric it could be how many errors
you make it could be that making a
prediction that it is benign when it's
not is more costly than the other way
around because the other way around
maybe you can do another test but in
this case so it doesn't need to be a
symmetrical cost so what you could do is
how about if I add more features maybe
the tumor size and the age of the
patient let's say that I were to do that
so now you have two dimensional maybe on
one on the tumor size if you do the
languages there are some errors but if
you have this you could find a line for
which is linearly separable so now I
added another feature another problem is
linearly separable that would be a good
thing in this case the the separation is
that you have a hyperplane in this case
there are three numbers alpha beta and
lambda that you need to figure out from
the trend data that will come up with
that line and that's what the learning
algorithm is and in this case is
linearly separable of course if it is
not linearly separable even after you
add a couple of features you need to add
maybe more what is the clump thickness
that uniformity of the cell size what is
this that you know that and that's the
game and maybe you need to use also
other classifiers so that's just the
basic simple one so the first a least
well-known neural network is the
perceptron back in the 50s and in this
case the question is how do you learn
these coefficients and Rosenblatt
suggested let's start with some random
line there and I will do it eration x'
and I will measure this and I will move
basically through the gradient as we
will see later but this is the formulas
that he came up with so the first time
that I saw this I don't want to work on
your networks not just because of my
office made is not graduating him before
that as well I like to have a
probability description or some moral
that I understand why were doing this
like this seems to work but I didn't
quite understand at that point why I was
working there for I couldn't extend it
so that's one of the reasons why I was
not interested in your networks back
then because I did read some of these
papers but what this would do is do one
iteration based on the previous one plus
that
difference between what the system is
producing and what the supervised label
is n times the features and if you do
that the the line will be moving until
eventually it converges and it may take
several iterations so that's the basic
idea of perception back in the 50s and
it was a powerful technique but also
before I go to the prom that it cannot
solve nonlinear manifold problems which
of course we all know which we need the
multi-layer perception let me give you a
least one explanation of the many ways
that you can view the perception problem
that at least I personally like which is
since I'm uncommon from the
probabilistic theory point of view can I
explain this come up with that equation
looking from probability theory is that
possible more traditional machine
learning so imagine if I say I want to
find out the probability of H which is
going to be the output in this case H
stands for hidden later but in this case
just one layer and V is the visible and
I'm going to make an assumption that is
a log linear model basically it's e to
the linear combination of V H and
actually the proud of them and there is
like some coefficients vector B a vector
C and in a matrix W that I want to learn
lurtz let's say that I have that
function we will see that if we have
that you actually can derive the
previous formula this is how you do it I
have the conditional probability which
is what I care what is the if I know the
visible vector the observation can I
predict the probability of H and if I
use Bayes rule I divide this and I can
expand both components for V both H 0
and 1 in this case it's binary variables
I replace this thing here and you can
see that I can get rid of e to the B
transpose V it goes and you get that
formula there and moreover now I can say
well what happens what is the polity of
HP in 1 what is the probability that the
output is 1 and if you set it up you get
this and there you go that if you call
it a C+ Vita
suppose w that's the signal the famous
sigmoid function so that's a lease and
there many ways of deriving this but
that's the way again
I like it because I can see okay now I
understand why you get that you get
these numbers you multiply them by the
W's you sum them up you pass them
through this non-linearity with the
sigmoid function which is zero when X
goes to minus infinity and one when X
goes to infinity and then that's
essentially the function that was using
the perception so now the loss function
I want to be able to minimize errors in
some form like I see the the network
produces at an output is it a good or
not and you look at the target and now
you need to find like something that
minimizes that difference in some
capacity you could do Euclidean distance
and for some applications that works but
here we're talking about outputting a
probability density function in for a
polity density function you clean
business is not the best distance in
fact there's the and there are different
distance measures for probability
measures but KL divergence is a popular
one across entropy depends on how you
look at it so this is what we'll be
using it so I have a distribution P in a
distribution Q that formula which is the
sum of all the you know K values of the
space of the priority measure will give
you the distance between two
distributions so this one will be using
and if we have binary variables that
thing that we don't have a laser pointer
right no so it is you know just a -
steel law logarithm of y -1 - see no
reason of 1 minus y that would be the
difference where Y is the sigmoid
function that we saw before if you take
the derivative with respect to Y and you
do the operations you get that thing
there if you take the derivative Y with
respect to X you know just using regular
derivatives you get Y times y minus y so
interested in that when you multiplied
when you find the derivative of D the
divergence with respect to X is the
product of these two terms Wow
why - see this is these are moments when
I see I love math look at the original
things pretty complicated
lots of Exponential's and they all go
away and the derivative of that KL
divergence with respect to the variable
that you want is just the difference
between the what the system produces and
the target that's nice normally when I
use the derivatives things get much much
bigger this is like much smaller so
that's nice
so circusy gradient descent is the
algorithm that was used that is used to
hill climb in in this function so if I
have if I want to have if I have a set
of coefficients like the B the C and the
W matrixes that I come up initially
maybe randomly and I want to come up
with I see how well the system does and
I want to hill climb and come up with a
system that that's better
in this case regarding the KL divergence
or cross-entropy
so how would I do that well what I want
is I start in one place I take the I
move in the direction of the gradient
start again the direction of the grain
and so on and so forth until I think it
converges just gradient descent we'll
see why it's called stochastic in a
second but basically what I want is I
have a set of weights W which are the
same as W in the previous iteration
minus some constant times the gradient
and if you compute the gradient that way
using or you want to show in the
previews our formula you see that you
have that constant times the feature for
that dimension times the error the
difference between the target and what
the the system produce and that's
essentially the same formula as the
perception so now you I walked you
through another way of getting the
perceptron formula that at least
personally I like because now I say well
is that you're trying to find a system
that maximizes the probability of
getting the right decisions and given
this particular log linear model so you
can try not different variance you can
try all kinds of different ideas because
now you understand how you can get there
it doesn't mean that this is the only
way to do it
so now I show you a case of binary
classification so in many cases that's
too simple you want to recognize n
courses
in this case what you can see is the
cross-entropy is explained it's
expressed as you see above and the wise
is what it's called soft max which
colleague of ours Jim bridle coin which
is essentially the output of the
exponential and you normalize by adding
or the outputs so you take the
derivative with respect to Y and in this
case it's pretty simple but the
derivative of Y with respect to X in
this case it's more complex this is
simple if Y is different than J I will
spare you the steps but maybe you can
see them is pretty straightforward if it
is the same you get the y times y minus
y and when you do that the derivative of
D with respect to X Y you need to sum
over all possible cases you know like
you're trying to say for instance the
derivative respect to W 2 3 it could go
this way it could go many different ways
so you need to like compute all of them
is the sum of all of them but it turns
out guess what math comes to the rescue
is the same thing as before the
difference between the target and the
prediction so even though it's pretty
complicated
he still simplifies it which is amazing
right so the formula is the same if you
have a set of weights the new weight are
the next generations the previous weight
times this constant times the up the
output feature and the error which is
the difference between what you predict
and what the true level is and that's
how you train it the problem with this
is that this only can do salt burns are
linearly separable and one of the
reasons for the first winner of neural
networks I only talk about the second
one was discussion said well even simple
things like an exclusive or cannot be
learned by such a system that is
linearly separable so multi-layer
perceptrons came as say well if you have
if you stick several of them on top of
each other you can actually achieve
nonlinear decision boundaries this was
initially developed in an obscure thesis
at Harvard that had nothing to do with
neural networks and had like a little
bit of a page-one a feel a little more
by Paul word was
in the 70s but no one really looked at
that until almost a decade later well it
turns out that that was kind of like the
first time that this was proposed and
the idea was more or less what we've
done
just keep doing chain rule of it was
called back propagation but is
essentially take another derivative with
respect to something take time's the
derivative that's something with respect
to the next one and keep going down so
an example of how that works in this
simple tool a perception is you have the
errors which is the prediction then the
label the target T and the prediction Y
in this case super this sub the
superscript 2 means is the output at the
second level and that's the derivative
of this level if you want to maximize I
mean minimize the cross entropy then
when you back propagate you have this
product that we saw before times the sum
of all the gradients so you're back
propagating down and that is the the
formula that you can do to do the back
propagation just technically in
derivative and now you need to sum over
all all of them to be able to do it in
the output again of let's say this
particular weight or one of these
weights is the same idea you have a
problem of the feature at that point
like whatever input comes at that
particular point times the gradient and
that gradient is back propagated back
and forth so that's the basic idea and
the reason it's called stochastic is
that you could do this if you have M
samples just take all of your train data
compute the gradients move in that
direction now redo the prediction of the
whole network and your trend data and do
that again but it turns out of course
that that is very slow if you could
break your train data into many small
chunks called mini batches and it turns
out that you converge much faster
because you can take a lot of you need
more iterations than if you take the
full batch but not many more and because
each batch is much much smaller maybe
it's like a hundred to a thousand
samples depending on the problem and you
may have millions of data points or many
millions the
it could be much faster and
stochastically it will converge so the
idea is that this nonlinear networks can
handle not only this multi-layer
perceptions can handle nonlinear
manifolds like if I give you these two
points if I said can you give me a point
that is in between well so probably I
bet many of you would say well how about
this one
sounds like reasonable thing to do but
how about if I say well give me the
points in between but I'm gonna give you
a few more data points there are this if
I give you an S in ask you to do the
middle point in between this one you
might say all now in that case I might
pick that one right and the answer is
because the correct distribution doesn't
follow a linear manifold it's a
nonlinear and that is what the power of
the multi-layers is doing its extracting
features such as you unfold this curve
into something that is linear and making
the decision there is very simple so
each layer is learning features that
make the linear discrimination at the
initial that's really what this is doing
so now you learn about binary
classifications and there are many
problems that practical problems today
that can benefit from just a good binary
classifier you know we had in iPhones
touch ID as of a few years ago and
that's a binary program is this my user
or is this not my user it's a binary
task yes
yes that's really but the problem that
you tell is that that you sure not and
it could be full from many reasons right
but that's really the task is binary
another binary task if it is speaker
verification is this my user or is it
not it could be a different user because
you recorded it could be for many
reasons but the task is binary face ID
is this my user or is this not my user
you know again it could fail for a
number of reasons but there are binary
classification problems so just the
techniques that you've seen more is this
spam as we discussed or it is not spam
am i moving the watch because I want to
look at it is there motion detection
because if I do this maybe it's not
motion you know so it will have like
anything's they will have like a
performance errors it will make me all
of these things will make mistakes for
different reasons but there are binary
tasks there are all of practical
interest or is you know is this credit
card transaction fraudulent or not but
there are many other enery
classification tasks that are also of
high interest handwriting recognition I
see this which number is it which
character is on speaker identification
which of many speakers is this or word
prediction so now let me give you a
little bit of history more recent
history now deep learning and new
networks came back I told you the 50s at
20 the 70s but no one seemed to have
used it very much until the last few
years why is that so speech recognition
the fundamentals of speech recognition
of a modern statistical speech
recognition started in the 70s this was
1976 Fred jellineck our IBM who framed
their problem as some information theory
problem so there is a word string W that
the speaker has in mind I want to say
this and now the speaker box is
basically the acoustic realization of
that word string a now the automatic
speech recognition system is trying to
invert the problem if I observe a can I
find out W an estimate of W and from a
communique information theory point of
view you want to find the W that Maxima
the posterior polity of value the worst
sequence given the acoustics which if
you use Bayes rule you can decompose us
these two terms or if you want to take
the log because it's more convenient is
the sum of these two components so what
are this this is what we call the
acoustic model so if I give you a word
sequence what is the variability that I
observed in the acoustic signal and
that's what we call the acoustic model
it has to do just with the fact that
female speakers have a higher page male
speakers higher lower page some speakers
have this vowel in this context all
these other things and this is the
language more is they how likely is it
that someone is going to say this word
string and you can by separating them
that's how a lot of the modern speech
recognition systems work even today so
that's still from the 70s oh by the way
this lambda thing is also something that
was bothering me a lot when I started
getting into the field in the 80s
because well it turns out that the you
can get much higher accuracy by using
the lambda of 0.1 or something like that
so come on Bayes rule tells me that that
should be one so it bothered me for many
years until of course the modern days
people say well these are just features
the logarithm of P of a given that is a
feature and the logarithm of P of W is
another feature and if you build a lik
log linear model that's okay so okay so
what that says is that this model is not
very good and it's not as good as this
model typically so I'm gonna give it a
smaller weight I don't trust it as much
that's in reality what we do so let me
just give you a very quick intuition of
what the language model is the language
model is the polity of our word sequence
and you can just use Bayes rule to
Savalas priority of the first world
times are probably the second word given
the first word times the positive the
third word given the first two and so on
and so forth right and I wasn't there
but I was told by my advice for them
when Fred jellinek proposed this in one
of the meetings he almost got shot
basically because so well are you
like a complex from like language just
with this numbers this comes like you
must be out of your mind so it was not
caught with great applauses like at the
beginning there was quite a bit of
resistance because you need to
understand this and this is very very
basic is you just count I will show you
how the first things work first of all
there was an approximation so well I'm
going to assume that it does send the
priority of this work only depends on
the previous word or two maybe if you
depends on the previous to is called a
trigram
if it depends on the previous one is
called a bigram then you have four gram
and so on and so forth so it doesn't
depend on the whole context so you're
making an approximation and the second
thing how do i compute that ragam of the
background well the initial thing is i'm
going to do very basic just use my
fingers i count how many times in my
corpus i see WI minus 1 and wi close to
each other next to each other and i
divided by the number of times that I
see w1 and that's the maximum likelihood
estimate now the problem with that is if
you haven't seen two words together
you're gonna sign a zero probability
that's not good so the next thing is
well can I what we call do smoothing I
will take some pretty mess away from
this estimate and share it with the rest
I haven't seen it but I'm not gonna
assume that is zero and there were many
smoothing algorithms I will just show
you one that is popular but there many
others could turn in smoothing where you
basically see how many times it happens
and you take some of that polity mass if
you have this four times and give it to
the ones that happen three times and of
the three to two and one and so on and
so forth so that us assume some nonzero
probability for any sequence of words
they will have nonzero property there
will be low but nonzero so that's
international then there's a lot more
here and just give you a very quick idea
of how yes
so acoustic balls they were using hidden
Markov models and basically what a
hidden Markov model is let's say that I
take the word hot and what I do is a
decomposing into three phonemes ah and
each of them is modeled as a three state
Markov hidden Markov model and I
concatenate them so this was described
in this paper by Jim Baker in the 70s as
well the he called the dragon system he
went later to found a company called
dragon but the name is a long story I
won't tell you now but the name of the
company came from the name of his PhD
thesis and there was another papers at
the same time but fragile in the
Caribbean and the Baker actually went to
IBM to work on this together in the idea
for Gila Mark Morris you're you want to
stay and you can only stay in that state
in the next time or go to the next one
it's only left to right and once you're
in this and there's some property of
stay in the state or a probability of
going to the next step and then the
output probability is like if I'm in
this state I'm going to emit a symbol
that is a spectrum let's say and the way
what is the pro latif of input of a
meaning these for that well at that
point it was mostly done with a mixture
of Gaussian density functions and that's
how the acoustic models work so it turns
out that in the early well delay days in
early 90s there were speech recognition
systems using neural networks you have a
couple of them geoff hinton was in one
of them and Alex hribal and Morgan
Burrell are and there were others and
you can see this this was done TD NN
time via neural networks there's
basically some neural networks so this
is not new and a couple of decades later
when I went to talk to these folks okay
so now you're using this button isn't
that what we're doing 20 years ago
what's different like what happened
interesting
so it turns out there was a neural
network winter for speech recognition in
the 90s all of these guys that did all
this work stopped working on it and back
in 2010 things started why did they stop
working on it
well so this is a curve provided by NIST
and DARPA this is years and this is
where right in the log scale notice that
it's in the log scale so the Department
of Defense
DARPA started investing quite a bit of
money in the 80s in speech recognition
and the way they did it is we are going
to come up with as a task we will have
collections of data of people reading
something we will transcribe it and
we'll give it make it available to the
contractors to use a strain data and
then we'll run will give you a
development set and then we'll evaluate
it on some test set that you don't see
and hopefully by doing this and just
running numbers and numbers you will
hillclimb and get a better and better
algorithm that was the idea when you
could see it's one of the first tasks
they call it resource management this
was essentially a naval task submarines
positions in the Pacific Ocean things
like that but it happened to have a
thousand word vocabulary in very
constrained grammar so it's almost like
the Navy talking to each other they
don't use full English they just very
regimented words so it's a simple
language moment and first it was like
the first time they run it in 1988 it
was like 20% it's like pretty bad
wearing now after you run in the first
year you say oh there's this others I
have this idea no this doesn't work let
me try and eventually it went down to
the single digits and then DARPA says
well that's an easy task now you guys
know once you go below some threshold
you're in the noise like two humans even
we disagree at some point right so let's
pick a harder task and they pick a DS
which is well spontaneous it's harder
because it's not just someone reading
you're gonna have just have a
conversation among humans that is not
scripted you know ask you to read
another one is read speech also wants a
journal so they brought people so well
go and read articles on the world street
journal and then the language
is more very there's a lot more terms
that pass had 20,000 words many more
words in the year that they introduced
it born the air raid went up people
started working on and started working
on it
and when done and that's how a lot of
progress in the community happened
you've noticed that it plateaued in the
2000s there wasn't really much movement
there well so what happened is at this
time all of these neural networks for
speech recognition that imaged were
happening along here and when what's the
journal came they just could not even
run the thing so the reason why he
stopped working is they were doing
competitively for resource management
what is the journal came and they said
well it's 20,000 words much more complex
and not only that I give you a lot more
data and back then and so what I can
handle
I mean I'm running back propagation on
me on my you know little mini computer
here my son workstation I I can it just
doesn't it just doesn't run so they just
couldn't compete and that's why I
disappear so one of the reasons is it
was not better but it was comparable and
you hear but the tradition more
traditional algorithms were able to
scale you give me more data I can run it
here it takes longer but Moore's law was
helping us so you know you could still
run it in these neon networks were
already maxed out they just couldn't do
it so that's one of the reasons for the
winner now there is a spring too and I
was alluding to this science paper that
Geoff Hinton high in 2006 and that's
essentially the idea of autoencoder
and unsupervised pre-training that's
really the the key aspect that fuel the
renaissance at least in my opinion which
is you have these features and you have
a number of layers and you're trying to
have something that can unwrap itself so
you have this bottleneck meaning you
start from a large number of vectors in
each layer you have fear of here you go
to this bottleneck and then you're
trying to reconstruct it and you want
something that can take the space into a
low dimensional space in this nonlinear
manifold that is easy to represent
everything so that you can go back in
the unrolling and reconstruct this in a
compact way and if you do that you can
do it an unsupervised way you can just
throw all kinds of data that was the
basic idea so there was something called
deep belief networks we invited I was on
Microsoft Research at that time we
invited Geoff Hinton to come and teach
us he was working on a mist which is a
data set that DARPA nice had provided
for handwritten digit recognition and
one of my the people in my team lead and
said well I think this is gonna be it so
I'm I mean interested and he was in the
speech team so I'm gonna work on image
recognition so long fortunately I was
wise enough to not tell him not to do
that but he did it and then once he
figure out how it works oh well let's
try on speech so this paper was a first
attempt on a small task and it was a
little bit better than the state of the
air but not a lot so it was just trying
to recognize phonemes and then the next
thing happened where we saw what happens
if we tried to do a large focal
recognition and when they came and told
me or we got a 30% were a reduction in
this experiment I have never seen that
and normally I said well you probably
have a bug you maybe are testing on the
training data or something that I didn't
realize or maybe by accident it's
correct mm-hmm
something there so we wrote this paper
that in beam publishing in 2011 and
notice one thing by the way the previous
one has deep belief networks and this
one has deep neural networks as it as
the title and that's because their
reviewers told us we love the results
this is great stuff but don't use Debian
that's already taken is dynamic Bayesian
networks pick something else
how about deep neural networks yes okay
so we started using that and deep belief
networks became deep neural networks and
then you know on another paper on this
more elaboration by the way I went to
Google Scholar and type deep neural
networks in quotations and see how many
papers came up this in the log scale by
the way so because if you do it in the
linear scale is a woman right so until
then the
like you know 14 17 papers so this is
not new people have used that term
beaming our networks before but look
what happened what started catching on
fire now everyone says DNS of course
like it's part of like your regular
vocabulary right so that's kind of
interesting so what is that we did for
making this come back after so when they
asked me why is this different than what
we did in the early 90s or late eighties
so it's essentially this architecture
this is a spectrum which is a
representation of speech that has time
in this dimension and frequency in this
dimension so you essentially take 20
milliseconds of audio you take the
Fourier transform take the magnitude
square and that's what this spectrum is
and you keep doing it every time so what
this does is takes a window of speech
maybe like 20 frames like 200
milliseconds 100 to the left 100 200
right for instance and that's your input
feature so if you have you have maybe
like 800 input features because each one
is like a representation of the of the
spectrum and you have a hundred of them
right and we build five layers and of
course five is because we try a number
of them and does the one that worked
best and a thousand neurons per layer
that was like the original system and we
have 8,000 output labels so it's not one
perfect performing but one is performing
in context like the funding would be
will have a different output if it is in
Italy than if it is in Italian just
because it's pronounced differently
depending on the actual context right so
that's why it's 8000 and total they were
like 12 million weights yes yes
and then at that point we turn it with a
thousand hours which is way more that's
part of the reason way more than what
these guys used back in the 80s and 90s
they produced 20 hours at most and five
was not a new illusion so you had to put
a lot of data through because if you
don't the systems is very hard to to get
them to do better but if you do they
scale very nicely you are more data room
you are more layers and even then it's
because of GPUs GPUs were developed for
video games but it turns out that
they're great at doing matrix multiplies
so we started using them and that made
it possible so even with a CPU it took a
week on a GPU firm imagine how to take
on CPU sling you know we still be
waiting and you run the first experiment
it doesn't work the first time so it's
not just one week one week to see ah we
messed up okay let's try this
ah we messed up again after a number of
weeks hopefully you get something right
so it's not just a one week
unfortunately so that's really what
happened
well the hmm we have an alignment as a
segmentation so if you have if someone
tells you the worst string we do the for
selenium we say well we know what the
hmm concatenation is we know because for
training we just need to find out where
is the alignment which frame belongs
into which state once we've done that
that's the supervised label for that
frame you have that label in you and you
have the speed in the spectrum so that's
the supervised information that enclosed
into the DNN and that's for the output
of of the DN n is the each of the output
there are probabilities of each of the
states in the hidden n th hidden
microphone so so what was new so
algorithms one of the differences if you
look at the neural networks in the 80s
and 90s for speech they were just
outputting the priority of autonomy like
T and that's it and if you do just that
it doesn't really work that much better
we model all a thousand
context-dependent variations and they do
you think of that back then it's not
like they didn't you just couldn't do it
like just their computation this is not
possible not to mention they may not say
well would that even work but that was
key that was a key thing now if they
have had the computation the GPU and the
data there is a very good chance smart
people they would have done it too
20 years earlier but they didn't
unsupervised pre-training I was alluding
to the 2006 science paper by Geoff
Hinton which is like or training all of
these things is difficult because of the
vanishing gradient strain all these
nonlinear things it can get stuck in so
many non are global Optima that if you
get stuck there how do you get unstuck
your ins are maximum but is far away
from the best one so the unsupervised
pre-training of doing this unrolling was
like we thought okay that's key so that
you can initialize and you're kind of
like in the right neighborhood and just
the gradient descent will just take it
just to the to the truly global optimum
so we use that in deeper networks back
then they had only try three that's all
but you cannot tell me that the new
thing is deep because now you have five
is just a number well it does matter
right if you could they couldn't do it
just because of computation but you need
at least for speech several layers deep
for other tasks you don't but for speech
the manifold is so nonlinear that you
have to do this if you want to get
resource now you need also need more
data
all of these stochastic gradient
descents of optimizations they are very
data hungry if you give it a lot of data
they will do well if you don't hard to
converge you know so large data in some
variations in in algorithms yes
yes so we take the Fourier transform man
you square and we will complete some
filters so like what is the sum of
magnitude squares in these 200 Hertz
region and as as the frequency increases
the width of the filter increases too so
it's trying to simulate a filter Bank
and then once we do that we de correlate
this with our DCT with a cosine
transform and that's why we get like 13
or so numbers per frame times 100 in
this case I think this system was like
20,000 words this particular one of
course now we have more this is back
2010 that was our first experiment then
GPUs again you have a lot more data a
lot more layers a lot more computation
you have to have the GPUs if we didn't
have that so that was like another
reason it turns out that later on we
thought this and supervisory training
was critical but then we run an
experiment turns out that it's not it's
just that it helped us get a good
solution and now so what what happens if
when if we take it away it turns out if
you are clever with the learning rate
and all this other and there's some art
there then you don't need it it still
helps if you don't have a lot of data
this caught fire I mean after that
everyone was talking about DNS have a
deep learnings couple of years later the
image processing community started using
it boom you know totally shudder all of
the image net standard databases the
array was just crashing down much more
one thing that I like about images is
that it's easier to expect to give some
intuition about what the deep learning
is doing like if this is your input
image if you look at what are the output
neurons of the first layer doing and you
look at where they have the most
activation they're basically detecting
edges there's that's all they are doing
so they're extracting features that are
very linear very simple then the next
layer is combining these features in
particular combinations and you can see
that you see kind of person you can see
kinda like an eye you can see
a little bit of a nose and then the last
one is true faces different faces so
what a deep network is doing it's kind
of like a linear system finding some
features but it's not done it passes to
the next one which finds another set of
features that linear combinations of the
previous features and so on and so forth
and once you do that Indian is a
nonlinear classifier and it's quite
powerful in the case of speech it's
harder to visualize but it's doing
something similar as well this is
another example of image 9 so this is
what we did in 2010 so what's happened
in the last seven years
well it's this the new tool lots of
people started looking at the problem
and trying all kinds of combinations and
there are some new things well the hmms
the hidden microphones are still here
they haven't gone away with some
exceptions the training criteria has
come from cross-entropy to MMI sequence
level essentially before we're trying to
say well is this 200 milliseconds this
tea when preceded by an e and followed
by a R in all this is or is it an S it's
a classifier just for this sequence but
that's not really what you want what you
want is did I get the centers right and
by doing sequence level optimization you
can avoid some of the independence
assumptions that you're implicitly
making in the cross entropy in that hops
that's one of the things that give you
another 10 or 20 percent relative
improvement features we started with M
FCC which is the mail frequency capsule
coefficients you ask a question on the
features we have these filter ranks and
we took the DCT and that's because when
you do that they are more uncorrelated
and those were that was a good thing to
do back in this 80s when if you didn't
make that assumption the Gaussian
mixture density is just you didn't work
because you assumed that it had to be
diagonal covariance matrices and if you
have full coverage metrics you couldn't
train them or so that was helpful but it
turns out that deep neural networks they
don't they don't care and in fact if you
don't use it you can slightly better
results so let's work in
get and maybe not much but maybe 5%
relative and then there all kinds of are
things that the feel has done regarding
training and regularization so batch
normalization I won't go into the
details you can ask me later if you're
interested tricks that can help you
train without being an artist and so
what is the learning right correct am i
initializing properly or doing
distributed circus grading descent so
you can train many different machines
and combine them things like draw powder
and more so the things that have helped
either converge faster or achieve a
better optimal point or more and there
are many other acronyms I won't go into
it but there is convolutional neural
networks or connection temporal
classification or convolutional lon
short-term memory deep neural networks
all kinds of things and all of them have
some boost some more for language bonus
I didn't I spend most of the time
talking agroco signals because the big
Revolution speech has been in acoustic
models that's where the biggest gap has
been improvement but language models
have benefited from on your networks too
often the best ones are recurrent neural
networks but because you cannot use them
in the first pass there's low often
using the second pass you provide a set
of candidates and you risk or that and
more data and the best thing is data
there was something that Bob Mercer IBM
said in the eighties there is no data
like more data and that's really true
more data makes everything better even a
simple system without all the bells and
whistles and that's the number one thing
that you can do just get a lot of data
and good data even a simple algorithm in
your network will do one in even more
GPUs now you have all these fancy things
anymore GPS so that's kind of like what
the state is I'll skip this because I'm
and there's still a lot more to do I
mean you mentioned that we're not done
and we're definitely not done common
sense which is what is missing in honor
of these systems is the least common of
all senses so adding that into computers
that's what we need to get into true AI
so I wanted to I don't know how much
more time I have probably so I'll give
you just a quick idea of what what is
this good for um okay so we at least I
mean a lot of companies are using this
that's why I hope that you're going to
deep learning and machine learning
artificial changes there's lots of jobs
these are some sample of the things that
we are using in products if you have an
iPhone you are using this even though
you may not know for example own device
recognition it take turns out that you
take a picture and you as well
I like wine I go and sometimes take
pictures of these bottles and I can just
type wine and all these pictures come up
and I didn't annotate them it happens
all on your phone so this is own device
scene recognition I didn't know that
most people already did another or
portrait mode you may have seen in one
of the latest iPhones well you can take
this picture and it blurs the background
which is kind of like what you see with
this professional cameras well it turns
out that it's all done digitally the
good ones well now you can do it in your
in your iPhone and essentially it's not
all detail is trying to say well is this
the foreground is this the background
and if it is I can apply a different
blurring algorithm language modeling
trying to predict what is the next word
handwriting recognition if you want to
type our write into Chinese recommending
news based on what you've watched before
and of course Siri
so I will give you just a quick
introduction to Siri I don't know that
we'll have a lot more slides I'm sure we
won't have time to go through it but so
you've you've seen our Siri in 2011 I
mentioned to this and it's essentially
the idea is to have a personal assistant
like those of us that have our real
personal assistant what's a while what
would I do now without one
could we provide this to everybody
that's the goal the ambition of course
very very hot big challenge this is the
high level architecture you have the
wave form and the first thing you do is
you pass through the sr engine automatic
speech recognition engine that will
convert they were from into words now
you take this words into the natural
language understanding piece that is
transforming this into another in a
space of intense meaning representation
and then there is a dialogue given what
I understood maybe I can do an action
perhaps like sent on a message you know
send tell Don I'm gonna be five minutes
late or in speak back and then speed
back and that's the high level
architecture and I'm oversimplifying
obviously but and then it's hooked up to
many apps in many domains you can you
say hey our hands-free and one of the
ways you can do is hey Siri what is this
or that and you need to push a button
you can also use in dictation some
people just like to compose messages
phones have are small they have small
keyboards you make me sick where you're
with your thumbs you can just push the
button and dictate many many people are
using this or even get your voicemails
transcribe you get a phone call you're
in the middle of the meeting or a class
you don't want to pick it up just let
them leave a voicemail and you don't
need to go and go and listen you can
just see what the person said for Apple
TV for example you need to type all
these passwords there's no keyboard it's
kind of painful so you can just speak
the password and by the way this has
happened just on the device we don't
want to send passwords to a server and
this is happening in many languages
Spanish Russian but in this is Turkish
Brazilian Portuguese Dutch time and many
more any happen
many devices you probably are familiar
with the iPhone and maybe iPad but it's
available in the watch you can talk to
the watch news it wasn't easy to cram a
deep neural network in here but it there
is one yes if I have time I will show
that's what I will show you next
it runs on the Apple TV which by the way
we were very happy when we saw that it
got an Emmy on the Mac on the car if you
have won a recent car home so I will go
into recognizing history what is because
we use this for a large show calories
speech recognition and everyone does
these days but I wanted to just go
briefly in touch one particular
application and it is we are doing
recognition here if I say hey Siri what
is the weather forecast for tomorrow I
know I'm connected to the Wi-Fi because
there is not no Wi-Fi here ok that's a
reason anyway how does that work if you
have connection it because all that you
can do is recognize history so when you
set it up you set up and you say this a
few times and you get your watch how
does that work so what we have is a DNN
and it's much smaller DNN much smaller
DNN than what we use for recognizing
half a million words which is what we
use in the regular system because here
we only trying to recognize binary
classification did you say hey Siri or
did you say something else or nothing at
all so you can do much much smaller we
have five layers too many layers still
important but not as fat not as many
variables but other than that is simple
and we have a threshold at the end and
the trick that we do is this needs to
work 24 by 7 like if I put my my phone
here is listening 24 by 7 which means is
running this near network all the time
imagine the power you know you don't
want a runner of battery because we do
that it took us a while and
the only way we do that is because we
break it into two pieces so the first
piece is like a special processor like
by the way the latest devices have
processors that are as fast as many pcs
not all of them but many of them so it's
incredible but they only use that power
for a very limited amount of time when
you actually want it to do something the
rest of the time it goes to several
levels of sleep and most of the time the
main processor is completely asleep but
if he's asleep then you cannot do this
if you were to do that you'll burn the
battery in like in an hour
right so these phones now have us
another processor called an always-on
processor is never sleeping but of
course because there is a trade-off is
much much less powerful right so you can
only do small number of computations if
you don't want to impact the battery
life so we have a two layer system
similar to what a cache would do the
first one is running all the time with a
very simple and DNN and then if it goes
in a nice trigger happy whenever he
thinks they might be close
is that I think it might be because it
doesn't want to false reject and
whenever that happens is wakes up the
main processor and says well now you
redo this with a bigger fancier DNN that
is more accurate and hopefully you don't
wake it up in vain many times but you
will but it's still better than running
on the on the main processor all the
time so that's does the idea and it's
interesting that to train these systems
and a lot of speech data lots of GPUs
running on the lab but actually you can
run it on on the watch the runtime so
the actual runtime the training is
painful but the runtime is pretty fast
the one that we have on the watch is a
hybrid from what I described so the
phone has the always-on processor the
small tnan and the application process
the big DNN that works here the watch
has only one and is halfway in between
in in computation but only wakes up now
my watch is is asleep I cannot see the
screen only when I do this and you can
see the screen then is one is listening
which is for a few seconds and that's
why you can
do this computation all the time so if
you don't see the screen you cannot
speak but oftentimes if you wanna say
that you don't just say hey sir you say
hey Siri and they will do that right so
I had I think I have eight minutes left
so maybe I can try to bridge through
another application of deep learning
beyond speech recognition which is
speech synthesis now this is the voice
of Siri that talks back to you and this
is the component so traditional speech
synthesis back in the 50s you know
forever actually in the in the New York
World Fair in the 30s that was the first
one the first publicly the demonstration
but what we call parametric synthesizers
which is a more or less synthesizes and
then concatenative synthesis came in
which is what I call brute force so I
just record I'm a bigger library of
audio and I'm gonna stitch together
chunks of audio and if I do it properly
I can get high quality so this was
called con kind of synthesis the first
stage is text analysis just trying to
understand if I see a dollar sign are
two appeared in a one is two dollars and
ten cents so doing that text analysis
there is a process OD generation so that
it's not a monotone is more lively you
need to figure out a little bit of
meaning of course it's not you don't
under the system doesn't understand the
others but it's understands it to a
limited amount it tries to figure out if
you dis at the end probably the
intonation goes down unless it's a
question mark in which in goes up if it
is a function word probably is not
stressed but if it is not it's prolly
stress and things like that and then
unit selection which is the part that we
use dealin's or deep learning for income
company so this is for selection of the
unit so we have the speech database we
run the recognizer to align it and
segments the database and then typically
we search for all possible concatenation
of units such that when you put together
there is a fun a cost function that is
minimized and the cost function has two
components this is the target cost how
well this particular unit matches with
this
funny that I want to realize with this
processor eat all this and the other
term is this which is the concatenation
cause if I put this together with this
does it blend well or is there like an
ugly seam that sounds bad and it's some
kind of combination and this is what
concur native systems have been doing
for like a few decades so if you look at
the concatenation cause in particular is
trying to minimize the cleaning this is
between the last frame and the first
frame of the next unit and the last
frame of the previous unit in this case
Euclidean distance and it used a number
of features where is the F zero the page
or the duration or the spectrum FC C's
things like this and the target cost it
turns out that back in the early 2000s
someone this could have or that develop
something called hybrid synthesis which
is they come up with a parametric
synthesizer that generated parameters
but instead of generating this all the
way to the sample they uses some guide
to find the units when we started the
TTS engine with the wall we don't want
to build two systems to have the best
system a parametric a non-competitive so
can we cheat and well how about if
instead we just use they mean the target
is just some statistics like the mean of
the of the phone from our train database
of course that's not very good if you do
just that well how about if we do this
and the preceding and succeeding phone
well it gets better because funny forms
change a lot in context that's better
the problem with that is you start
fragmenting your training data now when
you do that you have less training data
to do that and if you keep doing that
you know is the death by a thousand cuts
in fact we wanted to add all of these
features there are funny base syllable
word phrase I'm not gonna read them you
can see them many many more if you do
that then you fragment the data so much
then it's just not gonna work so you
need to be able to generalize and that's
where we came up with the idea of using
a neural network so you have all of
these features as inputs and the outputs
are just the mean of the targets that
you want to to use that's the basic idea
this particular network is called a
mixture density networks because the
outputs is just a means of a
distribution
other than that he loses the same as the
molecular perceptions of DNS that I
described before now
we also look at the role of deltas and
variances like there cases where you can
connect things in the four months which
are like these resonant frequencies in
the spectrum that you see that you can
see highlighted by these red lines are
pretty stable so you expect that the
concatenation should be this is vague
feelings like that that's not a good
unit concatenation so there is small
Delta and they're pretty stable but
there are other times when you have
diphthongs for example where the vowel
is just changing over time and thus
glides perfectly normal
that's what you expect so there since
move but there is a nonzero Delta right
in trying to impose a zero is not
natural in there cases where you got
from our vowel to a stop or to a
fricative where there is an abrupt
transition and that's normal that
happens in speech so we should we have a
large Delta between the two so the fact
that two units have a big discontinuity
is not bad it's expected so can we
generalize the formula before so well
yes what we do is we add these terms the
terms at the bottom is the standard
deviation we measure from training data
what is the deviation for that
particular context we will see that in
when you're gonna graduate this vowel
with this vowel the the standard
deviation is very small so any small
variance is gonna be highly penalized
but when you're here you say oh there's
a big variance so the variance is big
it's okay that that doesn't bother it's
not something that we should be bothered
with and the same thing with the deltas
in the concatenation sometimes you
expect 0 but other times you expect
something and that's normal so it should
not be 0 the difference between the the
last frame of the previous Union and the
first frame of the next unit so the
answer is output both the means and the
variances and that's what the network
does we did this evaluation compared to
the previous version which was done by a
third party and when we replace in iOS
10 iOS 9 and 9 to 10 and this is like
what we saw at that point
so hopefully you can see the difference
in quality even though reverberation by
the way we came up with this example
before the election it was like
interesting coins in us
no comment no more comments there and
then just a couple of months ago we
introduced a new variant that had not
only any voice but more fancy neural
networks in this is what the output was
I found a few matches for dark matter
available on Netflix ok I found a few
matches for dark matter available on
Netflix you can adjust the volume with
your Siri remote you can adjust the
volume with your Siri remote so it's a
different voice but it also has better
prosody and properties makes it more
lively so I think that's about all the
time that I have so thank you very much
hope they enjoy
[Applause]
you